achieving a higher level of intelligence
takes time and effort it's not something
that happens overnight
to improve your cognitive abilities you
need to develop habits that will Foster
growth and strengthen your mind
here are 10 habits that will increase
your intelligence and makes you smarter
1. reading regularly
regularly reading books articles and
other written materials can help to
improve vocabulary comprehension and
critical thinking skills
reading allows you to expose yourself to
new ideas and perspectives which can
help to broaden your understanding of
the world
reading also improves your ability to
focus and concentrate which can help you
to be more productive in other areas of
your life
2. learning a new language
Studies have shown that being bilingual
or multilingual can improve cognitive
abilities such as attention and problem
solving
learning a new language requires the
brain to constantly adapt and reorganize
itself which can lead to improved
cognitive function
additionally being able to speak
multiple languages can improve your
ability to communicate with a broader
range of people which can have both
personal and professional benefits
3. keeping a journal
writing regularly in a journal can help
to organize thoughts and ideas and can
also serve as a tool for self-reflection
and personal growth
journaling allows you to process your
thoughts and emotions which can lead to
a better understanding of yourself and
your motivations
additionally writing things down can
help to improve memory and recall as the
act of writing helps to solidify
information in the mind
4. getting enough sleep
is crucial for memory consolidation and
cognitive function
during sleep the brain is able to
process and organize information that
was acquired during the day which helps
to solidify memories and make them more
easily accessible
additionally sleep is important for
maintaining overall physical and mental
health which can have a positive impact
on cognitive function
5. staying Physically Active
regular exercise has been linked to
improved brain function including memory
and learning
exercise increases blood flow to the
brain which helps to nourish and protect
brain cells
additionally physical activity can lead
to the growth of new brain cells which
can help to improve overall cognitive
function
6. practicing mindfulness
mindfulness practices such as meditation
and yoga have been shown to improve
attention focus and overall well-being
mindfulness practices help to calm the
mind and reduce stress which can improve
cognitive function by reducing
distractions and allowing for better
focus
additionally mindfulness practices can
help to improve overall well-being which
can have a positive impact on cognitive
function
7 continuing to learn
whether through formal education or
self-directed learning keeping the brain
active and engaged by learning new
things can help to improve cognitive
function
the brain is like a muscle and it needs
to be exercised and challenged in order
to stay strong and healthy
continuously learning new things can
help to keep the brain active and
engaged which can lead to improved
cognitive function
8. socializing and networking
having a strong social support system
and engaging in social activities can
have a positive impact on cognitive
function
research has shown that people who have
strong social connections have a reduced
risk of cognitive decline
additionally networking and interacting
with people from different backgrounds
and cultures can expose you to new ideas
and perspectives which can help to
broaden your understanding of the world
and improve cognitive function
nine managing stress
high levels of stress can have a
negative impact on cognitive function
it is important to find ways to manage
stress such as practicing mindfulness
exercise meditation and time management
techniques
finding effective stress management
techniques can help to reduce the
negative impact of stress and improve
overall well-being
10. setting and achieving goals
setting and working towards specific
goals help to improve cognitive function
by providing structure and purpose
setting goals allows you to have a clear
focus and Direction which can help to
improve motivation and overall
well-being
additionally achieving goals can provide
a sense of accomplishment which can have
a positive impact on cognitive function
that's all for this video
thank you for watching And subscribe for
more videos like this